ALREADY THROW IN NEW YORK CITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALSO TONIGHT AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAMMERS THE FAILED LIBERAL
POLICIES THAT WRECKED BALTIMORE
SOME DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING
POLICIES THAT TREAT SCHOOL KIDS
LIKE SOCIAL JUSTICE LAB RATS.
INSIDE NEW YORK CITY OFFICIALS
APPROVED A NEW CULTURE'S
RESPONSIVE EDUCATION POLICY THAT
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO STOP THE
PRACTICES THAT LEAD TO OUTCOMES
FOR MARGINALIZED STUDENTS.
HERE TO MAKE SENSE OF ALL OF
THIS IS A CONSERVATIVE, AUTHOR
AND FILM MAKER.
WHEN YOU DIG DOWN ABOUT WHAT
CULTURE
CULTUYE
CULTUY RESPONSIVE EDUCATION
MEANS IT'S BEEN CONFUSING
STUDENTS AND KEEPING THEM STUCK
FOR DECADES OUT.
>> YES.
IT'S NOT EDUCATION AT ALL.
IT'S THE POLITICS OF
VICTIMOLOGY.
THE IDEA IS TO RECONCILE
MINORITY STUDENTS TO THEIR POOR
PERFORMANCE.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO IMPROVE THE
PERFORMANCE TO LOCATE A PERSON
TO BLAME FOR IT, NAMELY THE
SYSTEM OR THE WHITE MAN.
THIS IS A RECIPE FOR -- IT'S NOT
A RECIPE FOR CREATING EDUCATING
STUDENTS OR PREPARING YOU TO
BALANCE A CHECKBOOK OR START A
BUSINESS.
IT MIGHT BE A RECIPE IF YOU WANT
TO WORK FOR ANTIFA OR BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
IT LIMITS YOUR OCCUPATIONAL
CHOICES TO THOSE TWO CATEGORIES.
>> Laura: HE'S THE PROFICIENCY
CHART FOR NEW YORK CITY.
CHECK IT OUT.
MATH.
26% ARE AT OR ABOVE PROFICIENT.
SCIENCE?
GRADE 4 ONLY 18%.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE.
THIS REMIND ME OF THE '80s WHICH
THE CONCEPT TRICKLED BACK IN
THERE.
IT SAID STUDENTS PERSPECTIVE
SHOULD BE SEEN AS ESSENTIAL
ASSETS AND REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO
FOSTER CRITICAL CONSCIOUSNESS
ABOUT FORMS OF BIAS AND
SUPPRESSION.
CHINESE STUDENTS PROTESTED AT A
MEETING.
WE DON'T GET TRANSLATORS.
WHY DO SPANISH KIDS GET THEM?
EVERYBODY IS AT EACH OTHER'S
THROAT NOW.
>> YES, THE NEW YORK PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE THE MOST DIVERSE IN
THE WORLD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TEACH THE KIDS
ABOUT DIVERSITY.
THEY ARE DIVERSE.
THIS IS LIKE TEACHING ME ABOUT
BEING INDIAN.
YOU DON'T NEED TO DID THAT.
THE BROADER MEANING IS
STARTLING.
TRUMP ATTACKS THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RUN CITIES AS BEING CRIME
AND DRUG INFESTED AND RAT
INVESTED.
I THINK HE UNDER-STATED THE
CASE.
IF I WAS A POOR KID IN THE SLUM,
I WOULD RATHER BE IN A SLUM IN
BRAZIL THAN IN BALTIMORE OR NEW
YORK CITY.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE EVEN IN MUMBAI, I GET A
GOOD EDUCATION.
IF YOU TRANSPLANT ME OUT OF
POVERTY AND PUT ME IN A PLACE I
HAVE OPPORTUNITY I CAN THRIVE.
THE PROBLEM FOR THE POOR KIDS IN
BALTIMORE AND NEW YORK THEY ARE
NOT PREPARED WITH THE BASIC
SKILLS FOR LIFE.
EVEN IF OPPORTUNITY COMES THEIR
WAY, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PERFORM AT JOBS THEY ARE NOT
EDUCATED FOR.
THIS IS A DISASTER IN THE
MAKING.
>> Laura: WE ARE TEACHING THEM
TO AGITATORS OR PROTESTORS, BUT
WE ARE NOT GIVING THEM THE
SKILLS IN SCIENCE, MATH OR
WRITING TO MAKE THEM MORE
PRODUCTIVE.
THE PRESIDENT GOT A LOT OF HEAT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A TWEET HE
SENT OUT ABOUT CUMMINGS AND THE
ROBBERY OF HIS HOME.
TODAY HE SAID THAT WAS NOT A
WISE CRACK.
I REPORTED WHAT ON THE NEWS.
THE MEDIA HOPPED ON THAT AND HE
SAID I WAS JUST REPEATING WHAT
EVERYONE ELSE SAID.
THEY ARE NOT LETTING THIS
CUMMINGS THING GO.
>> THERE IS A BROADER POINT
HERE.
USUALLY THESE POLITICIANS CAN
PURSUE THESE POLICIES THAT MAKE
LIFE MISERABLE FOR OTHER PEOPLE
AND MAKE THESE NEIGHBORHOOD
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
THEY THEMSELVES LIVE IN GATED
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE
IMMUNE FROM THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THEIR OWN POLICY.
NANCY PELOSI DIDN'T HAVE TO LIVE
WITH HOMELESS PEOPLE AT HER DOOR
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND NEITHER
WOULD CUMMINGS.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING CASE